I'm Gary Stevenson
welcome back to Gary'sEconomics
today we're going toexplain
"Trickle Down Economics"
okay so trickle-down economics is the term used
to describe the idea that if you allow rich
people to get a lot of money, to accumulate
a lot of money, it will grow your economy
on the basis that because rich people have a much
higher rate of saving from the income if they get
money they will save more and that will lead to
more economic investment and more economic growth
this is important now because here in the UK
we have a new government Liz Truss is a new
prime minister and they are saying they want
to drive growth in the country by cutting tax
on rich people which will lead to the rich having
more money and growing the economy so we're going
to talk today about where the idea comes from
and basically why it doesn't work so
the first thing you need to understand is
what is investment? and what is growth?
Okay so as an individual you might think
if you buy a new house that is investment
from your perspective or if you buy
stocks and shares that is investment from your
perspective it's important to understand that
investment will only grow the country if it
is investment in new productive assets so for
example if you build new houses or if we build
more wind turbines or if we build factories or
if we build more productive equipment or if we
upgrade the machinery on our farms this will
increase productivity in the country and it willit
will cause growth so the idea behind trickle down
economics if you give money to rich people they'll
save it, then invest it and the country will grow
and this is quite a sort of it's a simple idea
from economics which is if people save more then
there must be more investment but what this
misses is that when rich people save money
they have other options other than simply
investing in building new assets right they
don't need to just build new houses or build
new wind turbines the other thing that they
can do and often what they do do is buy the
existing assets so you know in the last few
years we've seen a massive increase in the cash
holdings of very rich people in this country
and they didn't rush out and build new houses or
build new wind turbines or build factories in many
cases what they did is they gave that money to
their children and the children used that money to
buy houses and that's why we've seen in the last
few years a very big increase in house prices in
this country the UK and also many other countries
at the same time as a very big increase in cash
Holdings of the rich so I think this is the first
problem in trickle down economics is if we give
cash to the rich they're not going to necessarily invest
in building new assets they might simply use that
money to buy existing assets which means that you
and your kids can't afford existing assets so in
the last few years I've said a lot on this channel
your average Rich individual has accumulated about
100-200 grand cash that means that people from
poor families who haven't accumulated that money
their deposits are no longer enough for them to
compete with the rich families so what you see
then is that all this money has done in this
case has meant that instead of younger people
from poorer families buying houses, younger people
from rich families have bought those houses so
it can lead simply to rich people buying extra
assets the other thing that rich people will do
is they'll lend the money out you know um they'll
sit on the money and they'll lend the money that
might sound good if rich people lend more money
out but if rich people lend more money out
then not only are they lending it possibly to
you but they're also lending it to other people
so that means that when you go to buy a house you
are competing with other people who can get bigger
mortgages which means that house prices will go
up and the end result is that it's harder for
poor people with lower deposits to buy houses
because they can't get those big mortgages
and the people that do buy houses will end
up having bigger mortgages so the two big
consequences that we've seen from giving cash to
the rich are higher house prices and fewer people
from poor families being able to afford houses and
also bigger mortgages so more debt for ordinary
families so I think this is the the key thing
that you need to realize right when rich people
are given money they don't necessarily
go and build a wind farm you know
the main thing they'll do is they'll buy
existing houses and that does nothing
to improve the productivity of the country all
it does is make wealth inequality worse right
because it means that ordinary families have
less assets and richer families get more assets
and that that brings us to this this big
point of you know 'does it work?' and I think
we've got a great example to look at to
explain to us whether it works or not which is
the idea is if they have money they're not
going to build the wind farm themselves right
what they're going to do is they're going
to lend the money to the corporation tool
by the wind farm and the idea is that means that
corporations can then borrow at low interest rates
so hopefully they'll go and invest and they'll
build these things which will grow our economy
but we've had a really long period of trying
this out right since 2008 we had 14 years of
basically zero interest rates and that meant that
corporations could borrow basically for free for
that whole period did they then make loads of
Investments well if we look at that period
2008-2022 is actually one of the lowest growth
and lowest investment periods in the whole of
British economic history so when we actually tried
giving corporations access to very cheap loans
they didn't invest they they in many cases they
simply accumulate the money and used it to buy
existing assets then after that in Covid we
tried this period of just absolutely smashing
tons of cash to rich people and did it create
economic growth did it create boom economy well
what we actually saw was massive increase in
inequality, massive increase in house prices,
massive increased inflation and a collapse in the
cost of living and that is because of the other
fact which which I mentioned in last week's video
money is the resource which we use to determine
how we allocate the real resources like housing
food energy so if you give a ton of money to the
rich they will also consume more housing food
energy you know there's more space if you give
them money loads of money they will use more
stuff which means ultimately the prices go up
and you guys will get less stuff so I think
if we look at the reality of the situation
it hasn't worked if you understand the theory
of the situation there's this very simplistic
theory which they'll save more than invest more
but as soon as you take a step back and realize
they don't need to invest in new assets they
can simply just buy existing assets which means
ordinary families have less assets then you
see that what this actually does is increase that
spiral of increasing inequality which mirrors
that spiral of decreasing living standards so
you know I understand the theory you know
you know despite what I sound like I have
studied a bit of Economics I've got two
Economics degrees I understand the theory
um I think the theory is horribly naïve and
it simply neglects to realise that rich people
don't need to invest in new assets they can
simply buy existing assets from poorer and
more ordinary families um so I think it's really
really important that we push back against this
um because if you don't push back against
it then things can happen like what happened
two weeks ago where the Government tried to
massively slash taxes for rich people and that
will massively decrease your standard of living
um I think what is very interesting is that you
know financial markets refused it and I think
that is in this instance very very fortunate
but that doesn't take away from the fact that we
are still in a situation where during Covid
£600 billion was transferred from the government
to the rich, now as part of trying to fix the
energy crisis another 150 billion pounds is going
to be transferred from the government to the rich
they're trying to convince you it's going to grow
the economy but in reality it's going to mean
ordinary families lose their assets, younger
people from ordinary families can't buy homes
um the rich will get a bigger and bigger share
of consumption which means ordinary families
living standards will decrease so basically
the end message of this video is that um
and I think people already know this
trickle down economics it is an idea
there's some thinking behind it
it'shorribly simplistic and it doesn't work
um if you allow inequality to increase especially
if you're allowed to increase massively like it
has done in the last few years they're living
standards for ordinary families will decrease
um oh the last thing I wanted
to add was you know
if you give a ton of money to rich people
even if they do give it to businesses
businesses are not going to grow not going to
invest in growing their the size of their product
if the middle class can't spend and what we've
done in the last few years is massively crushed
the spending power of ordinary families so
if you combine these two things at the same
time crushing the spending part of ordinary
families giving a ton of cash to the rich
of course they're not going to invest in growing
businesses you know what we're actually seeing
is businesses shutting down you know local pubs
are shutting down because people cannot afford
to go to those places so um if
you want to grow the economy
you need to have a strong consumer businesses
will not invest and grow unless there's customers
and in order to do that you need to get more
money in the pockets of ordinary families
um if you give it instead to the rich, prices will
go up and ordinary families will get poorer so
um so yeah um trickle down economics it doesn't
work um send this video to your friends and
family, maybe who believe in it um and yeah help
us push back and fight against it thank you
at the moment these guys are profiting from a
crisis that is going to keep our economy in a
stump for 50 years. there is one other thing
they can do with that mass amount of income
they can buy your mum's house